welcome everyone to new coffee break
here on my channel firm learning my name
is heinrich i'm a former mckinsey
consultant and on my channel i want to
help you to become successful in the
first years of your career and today i
want to share with you 10 tips to
communicate better and be perceived as
more senior on the job some of these
tips are quite sneaky quite juicy i can
promise you that all of them are highly
effective so let's get into it with tip
number one so sometimes from a colleague
or client you will hear an expression or
a concept that you don't know yet and
many people will just ask i don't know
this what does this mean can you please
explain this to me and of course this
implies that you have no idea about what
this is about you might be perceived as
not really knowledgeable so next time
this happens to you try instead to say
something like what does this expression
mean to you what do you understand with
this term because this implies that
actually you know what this expression
means but you even have this higher
level understanding that sometimes
different people understand different
things with the same expression so you
want to clarify it and this takes away
this notion that you have no idea what
you're talking about next step we all
know this we already have lots of things
to do with maybe already late in the
evening and now your supervisor your
leadership your team need approaches you
want you to do even more so what a
junior person might reply to this is
something like i just cannot do it i
have too many things to do can you
please ask someone else to help you with
that and of course this usually doesn't
give the best vibes it doesn't show the
best attitude so instead try saying
something like sure let's look into this
together can you please help me
re-prioritize my tasks for the rest of
the day because this shows that yes you
are willing to do it you just need the
help from the other person to decide
what the most important things are that
need to get done today this evening or
this week next tip a mistake that many
people do is that they end their
sentences always on a high pitch so they
go up with their voice at the end of
every sentence and this might look
something like this so you share an idea
and then this leads to this other thing
and actually you also have this other
thing to share and then there's also
this other aspect that's relevant
so always at the end of every sentence
the pitch goes up and this leaves the
people not really engaged this takes
away gravitas takes away importance from
the things that you say instead try to
end every sentence with your pitch of
your voice going down
so say something like this i have this
very important idea that today i want to
share with you it is really something
that will make a big contribution to the
work at the end of every sentence go
down with your pitch this just adds
gravitas and underlines the points that
are really important next step you might
be faced with the situation where you
really don't know what to do maybe you
get a task from your leadership but you
have no clue on how to address this on
how to structure this here again a more
junior person might just say i have no
clue i really don't know what to do i
feel completely lost can you please help
me with that and again of course this
often doesn't give the best impression
instead try to say something like i
would really appreciate your insights in
helping me shape this approach make it
about the other person make it about the
experience the insights of the other
person and now together you will
structure and solve this may be quite
challenging task next step is to focus
on organization and team leadership
questions
juniors in meetings often very much
focus on tasks on responsibilities on
things that need to get done well of
course that's very important as well one
tip i once got is that if you want to be
perceived as more senior ask more
questions regarding the organization the
team leadership as a leader you're
responsible for enabling your team for
making sure that your team is set up for
success so ask questions exactly in that
direction do we have the right
capabilities on the team is this person
able to lead the project in the right
way can this person actually lead and
supervise this more junior colleague are
we working together with the right
clients are we set up for success so
these are typical questions that most
senior people will ask try to do this
yourself if you want to be perceived
this way as well these were the first
five of the 10 tips i want to share with
you today if you took any value out of
them at all hit the like button to help
me with the algorithm and of course
subscribe and turn on the notification
bell to stay up to date with my content
but now let's continue with tip number
six and this is a mistake that i often
see more junior leaders do and this is
that whenever there's a meeting in front
of your own internal team or maybe also
when you talk to clients or other
external stakeholders this leader wants
to present him or herself the leader
will want to give the result give the
presentation by themselves and then
often the team is just sitting in the
back listening to this junior leader
present try to find a setup where you as
the leader will sit in the back and
actually your team presents maybe not
everything but at least some sub
chapters of the overpresentation of the
overall meeting put them in the
spotlight let them shine of course
everyone knows that you will not have
done everything yourself it's clear that
your team will have done a good part of
the work as well so give them that
exposure give them that spotlight and
this also makes you to be perceived as a
good people leader good people leader
who trusts in his or her team a people
leader who wants to develop his team
members this will be perceived as more
senior as way next let's say you want to
praise someone for their job for their
work and here many people will just say
hey you did a good job thumbs up great
work it's great what you've accomplished
well of course this is not bad it's not
wrong try to say something like
thank you for your leadership on this
initiative thank people for their
leadership this is something that i've
seen very often most senior people do
and this of course instills also the
idea in more junior colleagues that they
are not just here to get some work done
but they are here to lead and maybe just
one small initiative maybe just a sub
part of the overall project but you want
people to take ownership take
responsibility
lead forward make things work so stress
this with your words whenever you give
feedback and give praise to your
colleagues next many colleagues
especially more junior ones don't really
communicate that much the winner
proactively reach out to leadership to
share some points maybe in one-on-one
team meetings this is where might say
something what i've seen many project
leads do with companies like mckinsey
bcg bain is that at the end of every
week they will write an end of week
email sharing three things first the
highlights of the last week the low
lights of the last week and the
priorities for the next week and i will
send this to the whole team and their
leadership be a proactive communicator
share your thoughts be transparent also
things that haven't gone that great this
is what will make you be perceived as
more seniors right next step when
someone wants to communicate an update
on a project or any other initiative or
train of thought that they're having it
will often go like this
so yeah this is what i think and this is
because of this reason and then there's
also this other reason and ir this other
reason is important this way
so don't do that don't communicate like
this this will be perceived as very
unstructured instead leverage the rule
of three if you don't know what that is
i highly encourage you to watch another
video that i will insert somewhere above
here where i discuss this in detail but
the basic idea is that you should start
always by saying something like this is
what i hold true and it's because of
three reasons so you always start by
saying there are three reasons for
something first second and third very
easy structure very effective check out
the other video if you have no idea what
this might make sense next step don't
talk too fast and strategically use
breaks make use of silence many junior
people just talk far too fast talking
fast is usually perceived as being
nervous and not being self-secure
instead strategically use silence just
sit there and say nothing especially
after for instance a client interview
explained a couple of things and you
won't actually hear even more just say
nothing
because for many people this would be
uncomfortable and often will instill the
other person to share even more but now
i'd love to hear from you do you have
any other additional tips that you'd
like to share leave a comment with your
insights this would be highly
appreciated big big thanks to all the
members of the channel thanks so much
for your support my name is heinrich i
release weekly content here next to me i
will insert some new videos if you want
to continue your learning journey all
the best to you until next week and bye
bye